so I've opened up JSON lint calm which
will tell us whether or not this JSON is
in the right format go ahead and copy
this object in just using curly braces
I don't need to copy far education paste
it in and click validate and scrolling
down we can see that this is in fact a
valid JSON what if there were errors
like what if we erase this comma right
here
well JSON lint would tell us where the
air is which is a big help let's see
I'll come over here I'll delete this
comma and click validate and we can see
that there's an error on line 11 because
we forgot the comma that comes before it
the good news is that text editors like
sublime text also highlight errors and
help us figure out where our syntax went
wrong